not suitable for children or those who
are easily disturbed now why would that
be individuals suffering from anxiety or
depression may not have a safe
experience playing this game ah
by playing doki-doki literature club you
agree that you release a 13 years of age
and you consent to exposure of highly
disturbing content okay all right I
agree
why wouldn't I hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to doki-doki
literature club no you guys have been
asking me to play this game for a while
now and I finally have an opportunity to
get here and well apparently it's not
everything that it seems to be but me
having played a lot of yandere simulator
can kind of see through the cutesy
outside and I probably know that this is
gonna go very badly for me but I'm gonna
play it
my name is market market market poopy
hit [ __ ] you boy it's your boy market
poopy come at now that's terrible name
Merkle flumph Lee Plumlee ma'am cool
flume Beamer Murtagh ma kappa Mad Men
Ming Ming ko Ming Ming Ming more it's
your boy more it's more hey guys it's
more alright more upcoming down the
street hey is that more Posse alright
you know it is you know I see an
annoying girl running towards me from
the distance waving her arms in the air
like she's totally oblivious to any
attention she might draw to herself that
girl is say Yuri my neighbor and good
friends since we were children you know
the kind of friend you'd never see
yourself making today but it just kind
of works out because you've known each
other for so long we used to walk to
school together on days like this but
started around high school she would
oversleep more and more frequently and I
would get tired of waiting up but if
she's gonna chase after me like this I
almost feel better off running away
however I just sigh an idol in front of
the crosswalk and let's see or he catch
up to me I overslept again oh but I
caught you this time more maybe but only
because more to stop and wait for you oh
you see like that like you were thinking
about ignoring me that's mean morph
that's mean well if you if people stare
at you for acting weird
then more don't want to think we're a
couple or something fine fine but you
did wait for me after all I guess you
don't have it in you to be mean even if
you want to whatever you say so Yuri
whatever you say we cross the street
together and make our way to school as
we draw near the streets become
increasingly speckled with other
students making their daily commute by
the way more have you decided on a club
to join yet a club more don't join no
Club morp told you already more not
interested in joining any clubs
morp haven't been looking either no
that's not true you told me you would
join a club this year did more I'm sure
it's possible that more did far many
conversations were more dismissively go
along with whatever she's going on about
she or he likes to worry a little too
much about more one more perfectly
content just getting by on the average
while spending more free time on games
and anime I mean more plike do nothing
else
uh-huh I was talking about how I'm
worried about you won't learn how to
socialize or have any skills before
college your happiness is really
important to me you know and I know
you're happy now but I died the thought
of you becoming a NEET in a few years
because you're not used to the real
world you trust me right don't worry
don't make me keep worrying about you
alright alright more people look at a
few clubs if it makes you happy no
promises though
morp don't make promises will you at
least promise me you'll try a little
yeah more gas more full promise you that
yeah hey why do i why do more blood
myself get lectured by such a carefree
girl maybe because she's cute more than
that more Piz surprised more people ed
my self worth more self relent to her
more PS seeing her worry so much about
me makes morph want to ease her mind at
least a little bit even if she does
exaggerate everything inside of her my
head med the school days as ordinary as
ever and it's over before mote Noi
after more pack up the more things more
upstairs blankly at the wall looking for
an ounce of motivation clubs cre wants
me to check out some clubs I guess I
have no choice I'm gonna stop with the
more thing good sit it's one hard to
keep up with them two really really
annoying I have no choice but to start
with the anime club hello oh say Yuri
CRE must have come into the classroom
while I was spacing out I look around
and realize that I'm the only one left
in the classroom
I thought I'd catch you coming out of
the classroom but I saw you just sitting
here and spacing out so I came in
honestly you're even worse than me
sometimes I'm impressed
you don't need to wait up for me if it's
gonna make you stay late for your own
Club
well I thought you might need some
encouragement so I thought you know know
well that you could come to my club
see Yuri that's the stupidest idea I've
ever heard of there's no way I'm going
to your club Oh meanie sorry is vice
president of the literature Club not
that I was ever aware that she had any
interest in literature in fact I'm 99%
sure she only did it because she thought
it would be fun to help start a new club
since she was the first one to show
interest after the one who proposed a
club she inherited the title vice
president that said my interest in
literature is guaranteed to be even less
yeah I'm going to the anime club
morp like anime more pink anime the
future of entertainment come on please
why do you care so much anyway
well I kind of told the club yesterday
that I would bring a new member and
Natsuki made cupcakes and everything
don't make promises you can't keep
morp can't keep picking up after you I
can't tell series really that much of an
airhead or if she's so cunning as to
have planned all this out I let out a
long sigh fine morbol stop by for a
cupcake but that's it
not gonna grab more more yes let's go
something tells me this literature club
ain't gonna be too good for my health
and thus today marks the day I sold my
soul for a cupcake I dejectedly follow
Sayuri across the school in upstairs a
section of the school I rarely visit
being generally used for third-year
classes and activities cre full of
energy swings open the classroom
or everyone the new member is here I
told you don't call me new member
my name is morph yeah I glanced around
the room girl one
welcome to literature club it's a
pleasure meeting you you got purple hair
you're probably evil saiary always says
nice things about you
seriously you brought a boy you've got
pink hair
you're even more evil than her that's
who's my guess way to kill the
atmosphere Oh more what a nice surprise
you're gonna die first I can tell this
evil evil are gonna die that's how it
works let's see welcome to the club all
words escape me in this situation
this club is full of incredibly cute
girls works not perfectly for me more
like you girls what are you looking at
if you want to say something say it
sorry
Natsuki the girl with the sour attitude
his name is apparently Natsuki is one I
don't recognize her small figure makes
you me think she's probably a first-year
she is also the one who made cupcakes
according to C or E you can just ignore
when she gets Moody C or E says that
quietly in my ear then turns back
towards the other girls anyway this is
netsuke always full of energy and is
Yuri the smartest in the club don't say
things like that I'm not smart at all
I'm incredibly dumb come on now Yuri who
appears compared ibly more mature and
timid seems to have a hard time keeping
up with people like Syrian Itsuki huh
well it's nice to meet both of you and
it sounds like you already know Monica
is that right that's right Monica here
it's great to see you again more Monica
that's a weird pose to strike after that
why is your skirt all flowing upward Lee
hmm something seems magically bouncy
about you
we do know each other well we rarely
talk but we were in the same class last
year Monica was probably the most
popular girl in class smart beautiful
athletic there's something evil about
her it's almost like she sold her soul
for all these wonderful things basically
completely out of my league so having
her smile and he sir genuinely feels a
little you you too Monica you too
come sit down more we made room for you
at the tables
you can sit next to me or Monica I'll
get the cupcakes this is gonna be a
choice do I have to choose I'm gonna I'm
gonna save real quick there we go hey I
made them I'll get them
sorry I get a little too excited then
how about I make some tea as well I'm
the mature and smart one apparently the
girls have a few deaths arranged
informant table a sewer I mentioned it's
been widened said that there's one space
next to Monica and one space next to C
or E Sookie and URI walk over to the
corner of the room where Natsuki grabs
the trap tray and Yuri opens the closet
still feeling awkward I taking it oh oh
come on come on better than that oh come
on Natsuki proudly marches back to the
table tray in hand okay are you ready no
I'm not okay tah-dah
okay Oh Natsuki lifts the foil off the
tray to reveal a dozen white fluffy
cupcakes decorated to look like little
cat I like how I like house a orys
reaction came before the actual reveal
like it was just a plate with foil over
and she's just like wow wow wow and then
lift it off and there's the actual cakes
and it doesn't matter the whiskers are
drawn with icing and little pieces of
chocolate were used to make the ears so
cute I had no idea you were so good at
baking Natsuki oh well you know I don't
know just hurry and take one Ciara grabs
one first then Monica I follow it's
delicious I haven't even eaten it yet
but it's good Sarah talks with her mouth
full and has already managed to get
icing on her face what a klutz
I turned the cupcake around in my
fingers looking for the best angle to
take a bite I bite the head right off of
that cat Natsuki is quiet I can't help
but notice her sneaking glances in my
direction is she waiting for me to take
a bite I finally bite down Oh
the icing is sweet and full of flavor I
wonder if she made it herself he's
really good morph like this one one more
black icing is this sugar I'm not good
Duff thank you Natsuki well why are you
thanking me it's not like I is that a is
that a soon dare a character
okay haven't I heard this somewhere
before made them for you or anything no
I thought you technically did Siri said
boo well maybe it's not like I'm in love
with you or anything oh god damn it
whatever but not for you you know you
dumped me you know I don't know oh god
I'm so cute all right all right okay I
give up on that Sookie's weird logic and
dismiss the soon dare a conversation or
as I call it the too soon did a
conversation URI returns to the table
carrying a tea said she carefully places
the tea cup in front of each of us
before sending down the tea pot next to
the cupcake tray you keep a whole tea
set in this classroom you're so
sophisticated don't worry the teachers
gave us permission after all doesn't a
hot cup of tea help you enjoy a good
book yes I like reading I like reading a
lot I really do
Andy weir just came out with a new book
he hid the guy that made the Martian if
you read that one I haven't read it yet
but it seemed pretty good I don't know
maybe don't let yourself get intimidated
you're he's just trying to impress you I
can see that and it's working on morp
more very impressed
all right yeah that's not uh insulted
URI looks away I mean that you know I
believe you I believe you I believe
you're trying to impress me I believe
that well tea and reading might not be a
pastime for me but at least I enjoy tea
I'm glad I'm glad too
okay URI faintly smiles to herself in
relief more faintly smiles to himself
and Monika raises an eyebrow then smiles
at me so what made you consider
literature club I didn't more push for
steer by sayuki ah I was afraid of this
question something tells me I shouldn't
tell Monica was practically oh say Yuri
drag dear bye say Yuri well I haven't
joined any clubs yet and sir it seemed
really happier so that's okay don't be
embarrassed
we'll make sure you feel right at home
okay as president of the literature Club
it's my duty to make the club fun and
exciting forever
ah okay when does the murder start cuz I
heard there was murder darn a murderer
Monica I'm surprised how come you decide
to start your own Club you could
probably be a board member for any of
the major clubs weren't you the leader
of the debate club last year oh there
you go with that pose again I don't like
you I've decided you're the evil one
you're the evil one I don't like you
well you know to be honest I can't stand
all the politics around the major clubs
it feels like nothing but arguing about
bub bud balloon bubble it's in blah blah
blah bit little bit blue I'd rather make
something something I personally enjoy
and make something special out of it
something and if it encourages others to
get into literature then I'm fulfilling
that dream Monica really is a great
leader I see you holding hands under
there URI also nods in agreement then
I'm surprised there aren't more people
in the club yet it must be hard to start
a new club you could put it that way
not many people are very interested in
putting out all the effort to start
something brand new especially one is
something that doesn't grab your
attention like literature you have to
work hard to convince people that you're
both fun and worthwhile but it makes
school events like the festival that
much more important I'm confident that
we can Rahl really grow this club before
we graduate right everyone yeah well do
our best you know more puzzle part of
this more pals don't want to be part of
this my balls so excited huh such
different girls all interested in the
same goal more ball so excited and
interested and goal but also more pop
boy Oh Monica must have worked really
hard just to find these three maybe
that's why they're all so delighted by
the idea of a new member joining though
I still don't really know if I can keep
up with their level of enthusiasm about
literature
so more what things do you like to read
oh I read Warhammer like a lot of
Warhammer 40k I like that universe it's
very good me following it very closely
well uh considering a little I've read
these past few years I really doesn't
have a good way of answering that I'd
like to Martian by Andy weir he's a good
author he's only running one bug - now I
need to read second book more more black
manga i mutter quietly to myself half
joking not Sookie's head suddenly perks
up looks like she wanted to say
something but she keeps quiet
not not much of a reader I guess I like
the pictures the pictures are good for
morp
more like pictures well that can change
what am I saying I spoke without
thinking after seeing Yuri's sad smile
anyway what about you Yuri
well let's see Yuri traces the rim of
her teacup with her fingers my
favourites are usually novels that build
deep and complex fantasy worlds the
level of creativity and craftsmanship
behind them is amazing to me and telling
your good stories such a foreign world
is equally impressive Yuri goes on
clearly passionate about a reading she
seems so reserved and timid since the
moment I walked in but it's obvious by
the way her eyes light up that she finds
her comfort in the world of books not
people but you know I'd like a lot of
things stories with deep psychological
elements usually immerse me as well
isn't it amazing how a writer can so
deliberately take advantage of your own
lack of imagination to complete and
throw you for a loop anyway I've been
reading a lot of horror lately ah there
it is I read a more bright a horror book
once once upon a time it was good and
scary I desperately grasp something I
can relate to at the minimal level at
this rate Yuri might as well be having a
conversation with a rock more blocks the
thing more better than rock Lily I
wouldn't have expected that Yuri for
someone as gentle as you I guess you
could say that I'm not very gentle after
all but if a story makes me think it
takes me to another world then I really
can't put it down so real horror is
often very successful at changing the
way you look at the world if only for a
brief moment oh I hate horror
really oh why is that well I just not
Sookie's eyes dart over to me for a
split second never mind
that's right usually they like to write
about cute things don't you Natsuki
you're just a one big stereotype aren't
you gives you the right
you left a piece of scrap paper behind
last Club meeting it looked like you
were working on a poem called don't say
it out loud please I'm super embarrassed
and give that back fine fine your
cupcake your poems everything about you
is just as cute as you are serious idols
up behind the Suki and puts her hand on
her shoulders
death metal I've got a scar I branded
myself with a hot iron once I'm into
BDSM don't join me I'm not cute ah
Natsuki you write your own poems yeah
well I guess sometimes why do you care
I think that's impressive why don't you
share them sometime no no no Natsuki
averts her eyes you wouldn't like them
or anything not like I wrote them for
you anyway I'm not very confident writer
yet I understand down in Sookie fields
sharing that level of writing takes more
than just confidence the truest form of
writing is writing one to oneself you
must be willing to open up to your
readers exposing your vulnerabilities
and showing even the deepest reaches of
your heart URI you're scaring me it's
very scary I don't like that kind of
talk there
do you have writing experience - URI
maybe if you share some of your work she
can setting an example and help Natsuki
feel comfortable enough to share her I
guess it's the same for URI oh I wanted
to read everyone's bones oh we all sit
in silence for a moment okay okay here's
my lean I have an idea everyone yeah
that's who kiyah OH I feel like
decisions coming up hang on let's save
again I'm a [ __ ] saver okay let's all
go home and write poems of our own
yee-hah then next time we meet we'll all
share them with one another that way
everyone is even let's do it
Plus now that we have a new member I
think it will help us all get a little
more comfortable with each other and
strengthen the bond of the club isn't
that right morp Monica smiles warmly at
me once again
hold on there's still one problem and
what's that now that we're back to the
original topic of me joining the club I
bluntly come forth with what's been on
my mind the entire time I never said I
would join this club music cut Sarah
must have convinced me to stop by but I
never made any decision music sudden
slam cut I solve other cuts clubs do you
Luka clubs to look at and of them lose
my train of thought
oh all four girls stare back at me with
dejected eyes
but I'm sorry I thought more like that
sister sound effects she makes when
she's sad just more more more MORE
you you all I'm defenseless against
these girls how am I supposed to make it
clear had a decision when it's like this
that is if writing poems is the price I
needed pay in order to spend every day
with these beautiful girls rights okay
I've decided then I'll join the
literature club and seal my fate to
certain doom huh one by one the girls
lights highs light up yes oh so happy
here he wraps her arms around me jumping
up and down hey you really did scare me
for a moment if you really just came for
the cupcakes I would be super pissed
then there's my lien then that makes it
official huh alright welcome to the
literature Club huh thanks I guess okay
everyone I think with that we can
officially end today's meeting on a good
note it was about to be a terrible note
and I would have had to murder some
people but okay everyone remember
tonight's assignment write a poem to
bring to the next meeting so we can all
share Monica looks over at me once more
more I look forward to seeing how you
express yourself oh I'm gonna suppress
morp self so good sorry severe spina
bifida oh yeah yeah
can I really impress the class tower
Monica with my mediocre writing skills I
already feel the anxiety welling up and
save me
emotions meanwhile the girls continue to
chitchat is Yuri in Natsuki clean up
their food hey more since we're already
here do you want to walk home together
that's right so Yuri and I never walk
home together anymore because she's
always stayed school after the after
school for clubs sure might as well I
guess Yahoo and with that the two of us
depart the club room and make our way
back home the whole way my mind wanders
back and forth between the four girls
Saori
Natsuki Yuri and of course Monica
will I really be happy spending every
day after school in literature club
perhaps I'll have a chance to glow
closer to one of these girls all right
I'll just need to make the most of my
circumstances and I'm sure good fortune
will find me well I guess that starts
with writing our poem tonight oh boy
[ __ ] that way gonna save some badge
about to happen I can tell it's time to
write a poem pick words you think your
favorite club member will like something
good might happen with whoever likes
your poem the most Oh
oh boy oh boy oh boy okay all right okay
all right okay all right
oh wait no oh wait no Boop
sticky damn it fear fear agonizing with
some parfait Oh Bob
[Music]
that's today flea album mother boob a
nightgown tuffet I am in congruent and
my mum um I like spinning mom nibble mum
mum hop explode from frightening uncanny
kawaii tenacious I love my mum mum
vivacious vivacious indeed ah hi did I
do good
I made a poem it makes no goddamn sense
someone write down my poem in the
comments blow it's so good
glad to see you didn't run away on us
[Laughter]
okay now don't worry this might be a
little strange for me but at least keep
my word well I'm back at literature club
that was the last to come in so
everybody else is already hanging out
thanks for keeping your promise more I
hope this isn't too overwhelming of a
commitment for you making you dive
headfirst into literature when you're
not accustomed to it well come on like
he deserves any slack Cioran told me you
didn't even want to join any clubs this
year that's not true and last year too I
don't know if you plan to go just come
here and hang out or what but if you
don't take us seriously then you won't
see the end of it that's that's that's
threatening okay okay hi Monica
Natsuki you certainly have a big mouth
for someone who keeps her manga
collection in the club room
Natsuki finds herself stuck between
saying mung Monica and manga manga is
literature swiftly defeated
Natsuki plops back into her seat don't
worry guys morph always gives it his
best as long as he's having fun
well sure I guess he helps me with busy
work without even me even asking like
cooking cleaning my room helping me
bathe how dependable ah yes yes I am
that adjective dependable amongst
excruciating and vivacious saiary that's
because your room is so messy it's
distracting and you always almost set
your house on fire once is that so
well you know live and learn and then
get loves you two are really good
friends aren't you I might be a little
jealous
oh well Yuri don't don't worry don't
worry
there's more than one way to skin a cat
no nevermind
how come you and Mark can become good
friends too um oh I don't know about
that
say Yuri uh-huh Oh as usually Saori
seems oblivious to the weird situation
she just put me into Oh Yuri even
brought you something today you know
wait sigh Yuri yeah me more for more ah
not really don't be shy come on it's
really nothing what is it never mind
Sayuri made it sound like a big deal
when it's really not oh you silly Billy
what do I do I'm sorry Yuri I wasn't
thinking I guess that means it's up to
me to rescue this situation hey don't
worry about it nailed it solved it first
of all I wasn't expecting anything in
the first place second of all anything
you give me I'd immediately reject just
because I'm that kind of person so any
nice gesture from you is a pleasant
surprise it'll make me happy no matter
what because I'm at such a low level of
happiness that anything's up from here
we sat so yeah I want to make it a big
deal if you don't want it to be no
matter how shitty your present is
alright well here Yuri reaches into her
bag and pulls out a book I didn't want
you to feel left out so I picked out a
book I thought you might enjoy it's a
short reads so it'll keep
it should keep your attention even if
you don't usually read and we could you
know discuss it if she wanted oh this is
how was this girl accidentally being so
cute ha ha hee
wowie wowie ok alright she even picked
out a book she thinks I'll like despite
me not reading much Jordy thank you
I'll definitely read this maybe I
enthusiastically take a book I'd be more
excited about this but I already
promised I wouldn't be whew well you can
read it at your own pace I look forward
to hearing what you think now that
everyone settled in I expect Monica to
kick off some scheduled activities for
the club but that doesn't seem to be the
case Sarah and Monica are having a
cheery conversation in the corner URIs
face is already buried in a book I can't
help but notice her intense expression
like she was waiting for this chance
meanwhile Natsuki is rummaging around a
closet oh great I'm really curious to
talk to URI a little bit more at the
same time I would feel bad for
distracting her from reading as a choice
coming up where's the goddamned choices
happening here I catch a glimpse of the
cover of her book this looks like the
same book that she lent to me more than
that she seems to be on the first few
pages ah crap I think she noticed me
looking at her she speaks another glance
at me and her eyes meet for a split
second it's a fate are we about to sing
but that only makes her hide her face
deeper in the book sorry I was just
spacing out your beautiful face I mutter
this sensing I made her uncomfortable oh
it's fine if I was focused then I
probably wouldn't have noticed in the
first place your beautiful eyes but I'm
just rereading a bit of his so that's
the book you gave me right mm-hmm
I wanted to reread some stuff of it so
he was fresh in my mind for when we
discuss it
to school [ __ ] now for any particular
reason just curious how come you have
two copies of the same book
ah well when I stopped the bookstore
yesterday that's not what I meant
I mean I just happened to buy two of
them I see there's something fairly
obvious here that URI isn't telling me
but I decided to let it go
I'll definitely start reading it soon
I'm glad to hear once it starts to pick
up you might have a hard time putting it
down it's very engaging and relatable
story about death is that so what's it
about anyway well death yes URI closes
the book and scans her eyes over the
back the book is titled portrait of
Markov there's an ominous looking eye
symbol on the front cover alright just
want to make sure I don't actually get
anything away basically it's about this
girl in high school it moves in with
their long-lost younger sister but as
soon as she does her life gets really
strange she gets targeted by these
people who escaped from a human
experiment prison and while her life is
in danger she needs to desperately
choose who to trust no matter what she
does she ends up destroying most of her
relationships and her life starts to
fall apart
that's kind of its kind of dark isn't it
URI made it sound like it was gonna be a
nice story so that dark turn came out of
nowhere
haha URI gently giggles all of a sudden
are you not a fan of that sort of thing
more definitely that sort of thing I
mean I can definitely enjoy these kinds
of stories still don't worry I hope so
yeah I totally forgot the URIs into
those things she's so shy cluesive on
the outside but her mind seems so
completely different it's just those
kind of stories they challenge you to
look at life from a strange new
perspective when horrible things happen
not just because someone wants to be
evil but because they have their own
goals and their own philosophy that they
believe in then suddenly when he thought
he related to the protagonist they're
made out to be the naive one for letting
the one-sided morals interfere with the
villains blinds I'm rambling
not again I'm sorry hey don't apologize
scary I'm scared out of my wits I peed
my pants but it's okay hey I have lost
interest or anything in you well I guess
it's alright then but I feel like I
should let you know that I have this
problem when I let things like books and
writing fill my thoughts I kind of
forget to pay attention to other people
so I'm sorry if I end up saying
something strange and please stop me if
I start talking too much that's
impossible I really don't think you need
to worry no one's talking to me in a
long time
so welcome now this means you're
passionate about reading the least I can
do is listen
so literature club after all ah well
that's well that's true in fact I might
as well get started reading it after all
you don't have to what are you saying
just a moment ago you said you were
looking forward to it oh let me just get
the book I quickly retrieve the book
that I had put in my bag alright it's
fine if I sit here right I slip into the
seat next to Yuri's ah yeah are you sure
you seem a little apprehensive that's
I'm sorry it's just the love in my heart
it's not that I don't want you to it's
just something I'm not very used to that
is reading in company with someone I see
well just tell me if I end up
distracting you or anything with my
heavy breathing I've got asthma as you
know I like to wheeze when I'm really
into a story alright I open the book and
start the prologue I soon understand
what your Amen by reading in company
it's as if I can feel her presence over
my shoulder as a read it's not a
particularly bad thing
maybe a little distracting but the
feeling is somewhat comforting Yuri's in
the corner of my eye I realized that
she's not actually looking at her own
book glanced over looks like she's
reading from my book instead so sorry I
was just Yuri you really apologized a
lot don't you hey why don't you stop
that I do they don't really mean to
sorry I mean
here this should work right I slide my
desk until it's up against URIs and then
hold my book more between the two of
them ah I suppose so
man this is the most romantic book
reading I've ever seen the tension in
the air is palpable URI timidly closes
her own copy
once we lean once we each lean in a
little bit our shoulders are almost
touching Oh
scandalous if ever I heard a scandalous
thing it feels like my left arm is in
the way so instead I use my right hand
to hold the book open I guess that makes
it kind of difficult to turn the page
don't worry I'll do it for you
ah there we are URI takes her left arm
and holds the left side of the book
between her thumb and forefinger ah
romantic I do the same with my right arm
on the right side of the book the way I
turn a page and URI slides it under a
thumb after flips to her side but in
holding it like this were huddled even
closer than before it's actually kind of
distracting me this is ridiculous hey
hey yari get high back off what about
personal bubble don't you understand
it's as if I can feel the warmth of URIs
face and she's in the corner of my
vision hey don't play that [ __ ] more
blacks it called when more parades are
you ready ready for what to turn the
page ah sorry I think I got a bit
distracted for a second a glance over at
URIs face again in her eyes meet I don't
know how I'll be able to keep up with
her ah that's okay you're not as used to
reading right I don't mind being patient
if it takes you a bit longer it's
probably the least I can do since you've
been so patient with me yeah thanks we
continue reading you already no longer
asking me if I'm ready to turn the page
instead I just assumed that she finishes
the page before me so I turn to my own
volition
we continue the first chapter in silence
even so turning each page almost feels
like a intimate exchange my thumb gently
letting go of the pain God is it getting
hot in here is it just me all this thumb
and paper action I can't hardly stand it
the vapors letting it flutter over to
her side as she catches it under her
thumb hey Yuri this might be a silly
thought but you want to get married in
the main character kind of reminds me of
you a little bit you think so
how does she well I guess she's more
blunt in a lot of ways but she also
second-guesses a lot of the things that
she says and does just like you know
like she's afraid she'll do something
wrong it's not like I can see into your
head or anything but they're kind of
reminiscent of some of your mannerisms I
I see
okay well ow my pride but also screw you
you're a sack of [ __ ] okay Yuri remains
silent for a moment
but morp that's probably a terrible
thing to have in common with her oh
that's so embarrassing that you think
that wait wait no I realize how stupid
that was of me to say I didn't mean it
in a bad way or anything sorry I really
didn't know you were self-conscious
about that horrible thing that you have
oh you're self-conscious about that oh
[ __ ] you should be but Wow how how could
I admit that I guess I'm more meant that
it's kind of cute
ah turned it around instantly 180 all
insults turn into compliments what are
you saying all of a sudden I okay
everyone huh I think it's about time we
shared today's poems with each other we
might not have enough time if we wait
too long
oh he Yuri exhales spared from finishing
her thought is it alright Yuri you look
kind of down I'm sorry if you haven't
been able to look forward to this that's
not it's fine your releases her hand
from the book causing it to close on top
of my
oh my thumb alright I guess I'll do some
more reading tonight what would you
prefer if I only read it with you um I
guess you can read around if you want
it's not like we have a closed reading
it's more of an open reading
relationship hmm in that case I'll read
a little more tonight it'll be more fun
to read with you after it picks up a bit
you know that's good reasoning in that
case feel free to finish the first two
chapters in your own time all right I
stand up okay I'll make a mental note of
where I left off in the book and then
slip it back into my bag okay by the way
did you remember to write a poem last
night yup sure did it's a bunch of
random words that came to my mind my
relaxation ends I can't believe I agreed
to do something so embarrassing I
couldn't really find much inspiration
since I've never really done this before
well now that everybody's ready why
don't you find someone to share with I
can't wait Cerie and Monica and thew
SaLuSa live elastically pull out their
poems Sara's is on a wrinkled sheet of
loose-leaf torn from a spiral notebook
on the other end Monica wrote hers in a
composition notebook I can already see
Monica's pristine handwriting it from
where I sit
Natsuki and Yuri reluctantly complies
well reaching into their bags I do the
same myself okay I don't know what's
going on and I don't know why but things
seem to be perfectly normal which
usually means that things aren't gonna
be perfectly normal so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to write a poem of your very own
write it down in the comments I will be
writing my very own poem in the
description I will
I can't promise it'll be good but I'll
write a poem yeah freaky I'll write a
poem doesn't have to be long write a
poem in the comments what Saul Sharon
check out each other's poems I'll be
reading through the comments and let me
know you think so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]